>> Dana: IF YOU ARE LOOKING
LIVE AT CAPITOL HILL.
THE CEOs OF APPLE, GOOGLE,
FACEBOOK AND AMAZON ARE GETTING
DRILLED BY AN ANTITRUST HEARING
AND, AND THAT’S NOT A SUSPICION
OR A HUNCH, THAT’S A FACT.
IF I HAD A NICKEL FOR EVERY TIME
I HEARD IT WAS JUST A GLITCH, I
WOULDN’T BE AS WEALTHY AS OUR
WITNESSES BUT I WOULD BE DOING
ALL RIGHT.
THE WAY THE NET WAS PUT TOGETHER
IN THE EYES OF CONGRESS IS THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SPEAK THEIR MIND.
>> CAN YOU TODAY ASSURE
AMERICANS THAT YOU CANNOT TAILOR
YOUR FEATURES IN ANY WAY TO HELP
SPECIFICALLY ONE CANDIDATE OVER
THE OTHER?
BUT I’M CONCERNED ABOUT IS
HELPING JOE BIDEN OVER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE WON’T DO ANY WORK TO
POLITICALLY TILT ANYTHING ANY
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, IT
SPECIFICALLY AGAINST CORE VALUES
VALUES.
>> Dana: THE CEOs DENIED ANY
BIAS.
YOU JUST KIND OF WANT TO CRINGE
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE ASKED,
BECAUSE MANY TIMES YOU REALIZE
THE MEMBERS HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT, BUT THEY
ARE NOT WELL-VERSED IN THE
TECHNOLOGY.
>> Jesse: THEY DON’T KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN INSTAGRAM,
TWITTER, NOTHING.
THEY ARE WORSE THAN I AM.
I HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE
CREDIT IS DUE BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE SOMETHING VERY SMART
AND IT PAINS ME TO SAY THAT.
THEY’VE LAUNCHED THIS CAMPAIGN
IN SILICON VALLEY FOR THESE TECH
GIANTS TO ROOT OUT HATE SPEECH
AND MISINFORMATION.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS IN D.C. I
AGREE WITH THE DEMOCRATS IN
SILICON VALLEY THAT HATE SPEECH
AND MISINFORMATION ONLY COMES
FROM CONSERVATIVES.
AND SO THESE PC POLICE TYPES AND
FACT-CHECKERS AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA HAS GET ON THESE PLATFORMS
AND THE WALLS KEEP CLOSING IN
AND THEY CAN SLANDER
CONSERVATIVES ALL DAY LONG THEY
CAN PLAN RIOTS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND OR THAT WILL BREAK UP
THE MONOPOLY IS.
THEY JUST SHOWER THEM WITH
MONEY, THEY PAY EVERYBODY OFF
AND THEY HAVE ALL THEIR
LOBBYISTS TAKE EVERYBODY TO
FANCY DINNERS.
THEY BENT OVER, GET AND THEN
THEY WALKED BACK TO THEIR DESK
THEIR DESK AND MAKE A BILLION
DOLLARS A DAY AND NOTHING
CHANGES.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, SO ONE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT IS UNDER THE GUN
FROM DEMOCRATS IS
MARK ZUCKERBERG OF FACEBOOK.
AND BASICALLY THAT’S TRUMP’S
TWITTER FEED OR FACEBOOK FEED.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> OUR GOAL IS TO OFFER A
PLATFORM FOR ALL IDEAS AND THEY
DISTINGUISH THEMSELVES AS ONE OF
THE COMPANY IS THAT DEFENSE FREE
EXPRESSION THE MOST.
WE DO NOT WANT TO BECOME THE
ARBITERS OF TRUTH AND THAT WOULD
BE A BAD POSITION FOR US TO BE
AND NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
>> Dana: WHY DO THEY THINK
THAT’S OKAY?
THERE IS PROPAGANDA AND LIES AND
HATE SPEECH AND THAT KIND OF
THING BUT HE DOESN’T EVEN KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE.
I GET THE IDEA THAT AND IT
LOOKED LIKE REPUBLICANS, YOU
KNOW HOW USE OF THE DEMOCRATS
WEREN’T ALLOWING HIM TO SPEAK,
AND BASICALLY WORKING THE REV
AND SAYING WE DON’T LIKE IT WHEN
YOU LIMIT DON JR., WHEN HE’S
PUTTING STUFF OUT THERE, WE
DON’T LIKE IT AT ALL.
SO OKAY, I GUESS THAT’S THEIR
MESSAGE.
BUT THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
ANTITRUST HEARING.
AND THEY ARE PROMOTING
COMPETITION AND HIGH-TECH
SECTOR.
THERE WAS MORE OF A THREAT TO
THE PROSPECT -- LET ME FINISH
UP.
IT’S MORE OF A THREAT I THINK
FROM JOE BIDEN AND IN TERMS OF
PUTTING IN PLACE LEGISLATION AND
PASSING IT NOT WHAT REIN IN THE
ON THESE MONOPOLIES AND ALLOW
REAL COMPETITION AND THE LITTLE
GUY TO GET IN THE GAME.
IF THAT’S THE ISSUE THAN I THINK
THE POLITICAL LEVERAGE IS MORE
ON THE RIGHT.
>> Dana: BUT THINKING ABOUT
THE FREE MARKET SYSTEM, AND HERE
YOU HAVE THESE FOUR TECH CEOs,
AMERICAN COMPANIES EMPLOYING
LOTS OF AMERICANS AND ALSO YOU
ARE HAVING A GLOBAL PRESENCE,
AND YOU HAVE THESE GUYS SAYING
THAT BIG GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
BETTER AT MAKING DECISIONS FOR
THESE COMPANIES THAN THE FREE
MARKET.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE HEARINGS IN GENERAL, I
DIDN’T EVEN WATCH THESE HEARINGS
TODAY BECAUSE I WAS HEARING
DOUBT.
IT TOOK ALL MY SELF-CONTROL NOT
TO DRIVE TO D.C. AND TP THE
CAPITAL.
WHENEVER YOU TAKE ANY ISSUE
WHETHER IT’S JUST US OR THE
INTERNET, HEARINGS ARE AN
INTELLECT REMOVAL.
IT’S LIKE -- YOU JUST GO BACK TO
THE TOP AND IT AFFECTS ALL OF
OUR LIVES AND IT’S ONLY GOING TO
GET BIGGER AND UBIQUITOUS AND
MORE POWERFUL.
SO THE QUESTION FOR
CONSERVATIVES ARE, DO YOU WANT
IT TO BECOME THE FOURTH HORSEMAN
OF THE LEFT?
THE LEFT OF ONE WHEN IT COMES TO
CULTURE.
THEY HAVE MEDIA AND ACADEMIA.
SO WE HAVE THIS POOR THING, IT’S
SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND ONCE YOU HAND IT OVER, IT
NEVER COMES BACK.
WE KNOW THAT WITH ACADEMIA, AND
YOU KNOW THE MEDIA WILL NEVER BE
CONSERVATIVES.
NONE OF THESE THINGS WILL
CHANGE.
TO JESSE’S POINT, I WANT TO BACK
IT UP.
IT’S ABOUT THE ACCUSATION OF
HATE SPEECH WHICH IS USED TO
SILENCE EVEN DAMAGE YOUR CAREER.
THIS IS HAPPENING EVERYWHERE NOT
JUST SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
GONE TO BAT WITH HIS AMERICAN
COMPANIES ESPECIALLY OVERSEAS
WHEN YOU HAVE GOVERNMENTS LIKE
IN THE E.U. FOR EXAMPLE THAT
WANT TO HEAVILY TAX OR REGULATE
OR CHANGE THESE COMPANIES.
THEY HAVE GONE TO BAT FOR THEM.
WHAT A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DO
THE SAME?
>> I THINK IT DEPENDS, THERE’S
NOT A LOT IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THAT BOTH SIDES OF THE POLITICAL
I’LL DISAGREE ON, BUT THE ONE
THING THAT THEY DO AGREE ON IS
THAT BIG CHECK.
JIM JORDAN TODAY WAS VERY
ADAMANT ABOUT POINTING OUT
ISSUES OF BIAS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLEGED AGAINST THESE BIG TECH
COMPANIES AND THE DOUBLE
STANDARD THAT DOES EXIST WHEN IT
COMES TO FREE SPEECH ON THEIR
PLATFORMS.
THEY ACTUALLY COP OUT, BECAUSE
THEY HIRE "FACT-CHECKERS" FROM
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS OR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT ARE
LEFT LEANING PUBLICATIONS DUE TO
THE FACT-CHECKING FOR THAT AND
THEN THOSE POSTS ARE THEN
FLAGGED THE PAGES THAT THEY ARE
ON AND THEY ARE LIMITED IN TERMS
OF THEIR VIEW.
SO THE IDEA THAT THEY DON’T
ACTUALLY REGULATE WHAT’S GOES ON
IN THEIR PLATFORMS IS
NECESSARILY TRUE BUT I ALSO
DON’T KNOW IF THE GOVERNMENT IS
A WAY TO FIX THIS ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING HOW TODAY WENT.
THEY ALSO THINK THEY ARE BETTER
THAN EVERYONE AND THEY ARE